Ready?
[Music]
>> Ready.
like
this
ever.
I don't know.
>> Yeah.
Brotherhood.
[Music]
Damn it. I see.
[Applause]
[Music]
Sorry.
Heat.
[Music]
I thought
you
There we go.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed that
awesome firefl Flo, it's been a long
time since I've uploaded a fire video to
this channel. Uh, this particular fire
video was captured at Fall Wildfire. It
was the 20th anniversary of the event.
Uh, thanks to Wildfire for having me on
the schedule and teaching some po dance
classes. And a special thank you to
Jennifer Ever Swanson for capturing that
fire session. Uh, and speaking of thank
yous, uh, big thanks go out to the
friends of the channel. Big thanks to
Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow
Toys, Pyroerite Toys, and Ultraoy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible. You can learn more
about all of these awesome companies by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And this
video and all the videos on this channel
would not be possible without my amazing
supporters on Patreon. In particular,
I'd love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now. Thank you all so much for
supporting my channel, my work, and my
mission. And if you'd like to get your
name in the credits or access to a host
of other awesome rewards, you can do
that by signing up for my Patreon over
at patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll leave a link to that down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Uh please go check that out and help me
out in my mission of bringing po
spinning and flow arts to the whole wide
world. Thank you in advance. And if
you'd like to check out some other flow
videos that I've done over the years,
including some fire ones, I'll go ahead
and include a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up on screen. Thank you so much
for watching. Make sure to get out and
flow yourselves today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon. Take care
now. Peace.